So the Lux project is an incredible way
to bring together the diverse collections
across the cultural heritage
units at Yale. It allows us to
fulfill our mission, to steward these
objects forever and for all people.
You should think of Lux as a doorway. It  is our way
to share the opportunities
to explore and discover what we have.
Lux is revolutionary because it's not
just another database. It uses the same paradigm
that major search engines do to connect knowledge
regardless of where that knowledge is from.
There  are lots of different audiences for Lux and so
when I think about Lux I think of the student here
at Yale who will use Lux for reasons of curiosity.
For the visitor Lux is a way to imagine a visit at
Yale that would encompass all of the incredible
cultural heritage collections I'm remembering my
days when I was a Art History student in New York
working on Charles Sheeler. Had I had Lux 20 years ago
I would have discovered the monographs in the
Haas Arts Library, I would discover the letters,
the correspondence of Charles Sheeler in the Beinecke
Library,  the objects of the artist Charles Sheeler
in the Yale University Art Gallery.
In building Lux we paid particular attention to ensuring
that the application is easy to use by anyone
regardless of age background or any other factor.
So when you log on to Lux you can quickly search
for anything that you're interested in.
There's a simple search box, put in a word hit Enter. But
you also have the ability to do really complex searches
using our advanced search system.
Each of us comes to the kinds of questions we ask as scholars and researchers
with a set of biases
and we don't know what we don't know
and what Lux can do for anybody regardless of what they're
working on is allow them to see dimensions of anissue,
a problem,  a topic,  that they just didn't know
existed. So if you get interested in a topic,
you're going to be able to explore that. Go down rabbit
holes come out here see something that you've
never imagined before that changes the way you
think about what you thought you were interestedin.
Lux is light and we welcome you to use Lux to
discover and to fulfill your curiosity.
[Music]
[Music Fades]